guerre en Ukraine dès le début hein il y
a bientôt 2 ans maintenant euh que
peut-on dire de cette évolution sur une
année de la guerre il y a eu cette
contre-offensive lancée à l'été qui est
infractueuse on peut le dire aujourd'hui
benah écoutez la première réflexion
c'est qu'on nimaginait pas vous le
disiez aux premières heures de l'assaut
des forces spéciales russes sur Kief où
que nous avons couvert avec cette
violence d'un autrage de ces combats
incroyables et puis cette résistance
ukrainienne on n'imaginait pas forcément
que
fin 2023 on serait à à parler de encore
de cette guerre et de cet incroyable
déferlement de violence hein Emmanuel
Chise nous le rappeler qui qui est le
théâtre en fait notamment sur le fond de
de l'Est he qui oppose les les deux
armées depuis tant de de de mois
maintenant tout ce qu'on peut prédire en
tout cas pour 2024 tragiquement hélas
c'est que ça va être encore une
certainement c'est quasi certitude une
nouvelle année de de de guerre avec des
bilans humains incroyables et là aussi
on est un peu dans une une guerre de de
de propagande je dirais puisque les du
côté russe sont les services de secr
services de renseignement américain qui
sont très très bien renseignés sur ce
conflit avance le le chiffre de 300 à
350000 morts du côté russe don ou alors
invalider ce que disait Emmanuel du côté
ukrainien c'est il n'y a pas de de
chiffre puisque évidemment le Baum au
cœur des troupes est extrêmement
important et c'est extrêmement central
au moment où on essaie de ravigorer de
recruter de nouvelles personnes pour
aller au front ukrainien mais on est un
peu dans ces 30 % en de ça de là donc
des chiffres effroyables pour rappel la
dernière bataille en date du front de
l'Est à advica c'est plusieurs centaines
de morts Ukrainiens par jour donc ça
c'est effectivement des bilans des
chiffres qui apparaissaient d'un d'un
autre âge on a pu voir aussi pour
dresser un bilan une infographie qu'on a
pu pour P voir pour voir le le le le
déplacement des des des des combats donc
ça c'était effectivement au début avant
le début donc de la cette invasion russe
cette opération militaire lancée par
Moscou qui je le rappelle du devait
durer 3 jours là aussi et je d'ailleurs
le crremmelin vient de confirmer
aujourd'hui que cette opération
militaire allait continuer puisqu'il y a
une disproportion extrêmement importante
d'effectif entre les deux camps mais du
côté du réservoir humain malgré cette
cette boucherie sur le terrain du côté
russe il semble qu'il n'y ait pas de
problème pour envoyer des gens au combat
donc il y a eu cette évolution il y a
donc cette carte qui montre l'avancée
russe qui a fondu sur Kief de le début
sont les combats de hpine aostomel et et
BCH que nous avons couvert qui était
d'une violence inouie dans des dans les
grandes foyers urbains d'habitation et
cet échec de l'assaut sur Kief et qui va
amener et ça sera sans doute la carte
d'après qui va montrer cette fameuse
contreoffensive et c'est pour ça qu'on a
du mal à imaginer qu'on en soit encore
là tant de mois après cette
contreoffensive de printemps notamment à
à Carson carkive qui a repoussé les
Russes qui a stoppé net hein les les les
Russes alors qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement euh pour pour l'état de
la la guerre pour les la tragédie que ça
amène pour des générations dans les deux
camps et bien c'est voilà c'est un front
figé plus ou moins figé Emmanuel Chaz
nuançait évidemment il y a des gains
russes et une formidable résistance
encore une fois avec une disproportion
incroyable de de de force humaine mais
on est dans un dans une situation
effectivement gelée figée et qui
inaugure hélas rien de de bon hein pour
la la suite pour 2024 et la suite va
aussi dépendre de l'aide occidentale
notamment américaine et européenne oui
et ça on le vit tous hein cet élan
compassionnel qu'on avait vécu au début
de la guerre où c'était évidemment dans
toutes les discussion cette guerre aux
portes de l'Europe alors là évidemment
cet élan convessionnel s'est érodé il y
a une érosion qu'on voit aussi chez les
les institutions les hommes politiques
les politiques l'aide à l'Ukraine qui a
été formidable puis qu'on savait que la
guerre était aux portes de l'Europe donc
beaucoup de dirigeants européens ou
occidentaux et notamment aux États-Unis
qui est le second front en fait de
l'Ukraine notamment pour le le fait de
pourvoyer des armes et bien on a la ça
aussi ça a fait un peu long feu avec du
côté européen le blocage alors que les
26 étaient d'accord par la Hongrie Orban
Victor Orban qui est pro Poutine
évidemment qui a bloqué une aide très
importante de 50 milliards d'euros une
aide financière fondamentale dans les
dans l'état de de dénuement de l'Ukraine
et puis les États-Unis c'est là où on
n'y arrivait pas c'est qu'en fait Joe
Biden n'arrive pas à convaincre ce
congrès pour des question de politique
domestique il y a les élections
américaines qui arrivent et d'ailleurs
cela pourrait changer les chauss siers
Donald Trump euh d'aventure allait être
réélu donc il n'arrive pas à débloquer
61 milliards d'Aid militaire le second
front américain qui n'arrive pas à
donner euh autant d'armes qu'il le
faudrait aux aux Ukrainiens donc
énormément de questions un un conflit
d'un autre âge et rien de bon
qu'inaugure hein pour la suite puisqu'on
va vers le temps long et pour finir ce
temps long bah évidemment profiter il
l'a compris à au président Vladimir
Poutine le président russe qui a lancé
Tess offensive merci beaucoup cirril
paayen pour cette analyse